I'm outside the CBS Broadcast Center right now
because the moment we've all been waiting for is here.
For over a week now, our show has been on the road
in the Drew van, driving across the country
from California to right here in New York.
And many of you spotted the van and sent us your pictures.
I've met some great people along the way
and who have reached out to us while seeing the van
we've met Drew Gooders.
I met a wonderful woman who inspired me.
We added businesses to our small business gift guide
and they went on a Barrymore tour
and found a snake named Drew in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
Guess what, it's Karyn and Noah.
(audience cheers)
Hi Drew.
We made it.
Oh my gosh, finally, you guys are here.
We are, we are.
It's so good to see you in person, hello.
Thank you for letting us put our logo on your van
which is just so well done.
Thank you.
You really decked it out and created a lifestyle, really.
It's meant to be an experience.
It's really not meant to be a thing.
It's meant to facilitate seeing the world.
And that's what this is about.
And also for the record
you don't need a van to see the world, just go.
Thank you for being the representatives
of showing people what's possible to do with their life.
Oh, you're so welcome.
We think that spontaneity equals joy.
Our lives are so regimented
and when you can break out of that,
even if it's for a long weekend
you have the ability to just stop and be in the moment
go wherever your fancy takes you.
I mean, it's this freedom that we just don't have.
I mean, especially in this COVID year, right?
I know, and yet people I think have been more inventive
about road tripping.
What do you say to people that are too scared
to let go of the permanence and comfort of their position
or job and hop in a van and go see the world?
I think that's actually changed a lot in the last year.
Living in the Bay area,
we were very close to Silicon Valley.
There's actually a new term that's emerged
called the digital nomads.
People who actually want to work from their vehicle,
work from their van, work from their car,
Airbnb around the world and work.
And I think it's a new thing.
It's a new emerging thing that I think is going to catch on.
A lot of companies are not going to go back to work.
And so I think this is kind of here to stay.
And so in our little way, we've contributed to that.
There's so many other ways that you can do that
and that have emerged that facilitate that.
Well, I think when people see your van
and see how livable it is and stylish and beautiful
it's going to be a huge source of inspiration.
And I think it's confidence building what you guys do.
Is like, "Go for it.
Life is short, live your dreams.
And make the most of the time we have here on our planet."
So I am so excited about this.
Now I heard there's actually a montage we get to watch
of the sticker idea.
My 90s zine girl that wants to throw Drew's News stickers.
I am dying.
I can't even help it or hold back.
I just want to see it.
It's amazing, we got to go to the best places and do that.
Oh my gosh.
Can I tell you where we did our favorite?
Yes.
We did Cadillac Ranch in Texas.
Amazing art installation in the middle of the desert.
We did the Twin Arrows trading post in Arizona
which is like these huge skyscraper sized arrows
that looked like they'd been shot into the desert floor.
Incredible, on Route 66.
We did, oh the Baghdad Cafe.
Remember the movie?
Yes.
Amazing, it's still there.
And then we did Sun Studios in Memphis, Tennessee
where Elvis got his star.
Oh my gosh.
Elvis, Johnny Cash, yeah.
It was amazing.
There are Drew's News stickers
right outside Elvis' studio.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe it!
Can I ask, definitely a highlight for me
watching you guys was the Drew snake.
I don't know why.
I just have a lot of affinity
for this albino snake named Drew.
A rattler I believe.
Oh yeah, uh-huh.
Yeah, oh yeah.
Was there any geographical location or landmark
or little cafe, anything that really stuck out for you
as, "Gosh I wouldn't have thought that that would be
such a highlight but it turned out to be?"
You haven't lived until you've watched
the sunset in Sedona.
I'm at a lack of words
for describing that.
Were you at that rock?
We were right there.
We were directly below what was it, Bell?
Bell Rock.
Oh wow.
We climbed sort of a third of the way up Bell Rock
and watched the sunset.
We sat on top of the van
which has a cool little van life shake.
You can actually sit up on top of the van.
We watched the stars for an hour and a half
on the side of the road.
We saw this really weird, we thought it was a UFO
at the time.
Turns out it was a bunch of satellites
that launched last week
that were spreading themselves across.
So they say.
So they say, yeah.
It is Sedona.
Yeah, that isn't far from was it Area 54?
Right down the road.
Right down 51.
Yeah, not that far.
Exactly.
And we just watched the stars and lay there.
And honestly, one of the best things about this,
we love, love, love our children they're amazing.
It's been 14 years since Karyn and I got to go away
just the two of us for more than a night here there.
Thank you for that.
I am so happy for you.
I have to say we found it surprisingly easy to let go.
I thought there was going to be more guilt.
I thought there was going to be more,
"I need to call home now."
We were able to relax.
I think we're going to go home a 100% recharged.
This was the greatest gift in these times.
Thank you so much.
That makes me so happy.
Oh, what a good thing to come out of this.
But we have to go to a quick commercial break.
But when we come back,
Noah and Karyn are revealing their road tripping tips
to make your next vacation so delightful.
And if there's anyone, I want to hear it from
it's two people that feel as fulfilled as you do.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪